alright you're done let's take a look at
my solution for the delete method things
are pretty straightforward we just call
db2 lead with the appropriate table and
the selection and the selection
arguments one thing that I've done is if
the selection is null I've set it to one
this makes delete all rows returned the
number of rows deleted and that can be
useful I only notify the content
resolver of a change if we actually have
deleted some rows this isn't strictly
necessary update looks almost exactly
like delete once again based upon the
URI we select a different table and call
the update function with the values and
the selection arguments and I only
notify for a change we've actually
updated some rows all right let's go to
test our function in test provider you
can see we've uncommented out test
delete records as well as test update
location let's run the test to make sure
everything works correctly and as you
can see everything passes we've done
everything correct for updating and
deleting the content provider